another boat another rescue mission on
the Mediterranean Sea this time 400
people on board including women and
children stranded between Greece and
Malta reportedly abandoned by their
captain
America's case
[Music]
a job not over yet as the Italian coast
guards attempt another rescue 800 people
on board another boat off the coast of
Sicily the German migrant rescue group
Seawatch says two ships tried to help
one of the boats but were told by The
Maltese authorities to only provide fuel
The Maltese authorities decided to not
intervene this is not the first time
that Malta decides not to intervene and
indeed to rather support the both to
continue navigating in those very
dangerous conditions to not take the
responsibility for their rescue and
delegated to Italy
one of the most common destinations for
migrants from North Africa is Italy it's
been a difficult Easter weekend with
more than 2 000 people rescued in just a
couple of days many have been taken to
the Italian island of lampedusa Italy's
interior Ministry figures say that 28
000 migrants have landed on its Shores
since January the 1st now that's almost
four times higher than last year
the central Mediterranean route is the
most dangerous migration route in the
world most of those attempting the roots
are leaving behind War poverty and human
rights abuses while they all dream of a
better future
not all of them survive
Al Jazeera